nous faisons des secrets alors qu'il
vient donc cette chroniqueurs autour de
la table et ils sont créés un secret
leila vous avez joué vous allez essayer
de donner de redonner les secrets à
chaque chroniqueur donc d attribuer on a
donc malgré les apparences je porte un
slip j'ai été vendus comme esclaves dans
leurs clubs échangistes j'ai travaillé
dans le x j'ai fait un road trip avec
colombo j'ai déjeuné avec le pape je
suis fan de jacques chirac
je sais faire le grand écart sans
échauffement jouer chez vous tient sur
twitter http mp sur facebook sur la page
de touche pas à mon poste dites-nous ce
que votre avis ce que vous attribuiez à
chaque chroniqueur alors à votre avis
qui malgré les apparences porte un slip
je porte un nom le dit donc elle
isabelle morini bosc
comme ça a pris auriez vous la voyez
s'en sont mis plein elle parle de rika
zaraï comme des fois j'ai des jus pour
rendre la joie de vie il vaut mieux un
script alors on va afficher tout de
suite la personne qui malgré les
apparences porte un slip
attention ça va l'amplifier vous avez un
slip aujourd'hui j'ai obligé de le
prouver
je vous laisse écouter ça va donner
envie tout ça vous allait booster votre
carrière texte attention j'ai été vendus
comme esclaves dans un club échangiste à
votre avis est vendu comme esclave dans
un club échangiste vous dit allez leila
christophe carrière là-bas des mondiaux
comme esclaves dans un club échangiste
vous voulez qu'ils échangent il a rien
je vous en prie non mais alors alors on
va voir qu'une autre il s'agit moi je
suis beaucoup c'est pas du tout c'est
qui c'est qui qui a été bon
les jets
c'est bien parce que on encore il ya une
oreillette il me demande lui d'expliquer
charbon c'est bon d'accord elle enfin
son or c'est le truc normal est normal
pour lui c'est énorme alors oui des toi
tu faisais une enquête pour un journal
c'est ça ouais non car je trop scam là
où les personnalités allait donc je suis
allé dans des clubs et dans ce club là
un club sado-maso j'arrive à une vente
aux enchères et comment elle chante
crise et chuchotements et donc on me dit
c'est inhérentes aux gens c'est revoilà
donc bon il y connaît lui il est capable
de te donner le numéro de téléphone les
heures d'ouverture a créé justement je
connais faites attention parce qu'il ya
de code ci sont ensuite poster sur
demande écrite au sol est assez et ses
hommes voilà et donc je me propose pour
jouer le jeu et qu'on prend pour être
vendus donc j'arrive au milieu de la
piste et puis les enchères montent alors
c'est pas de leur os et du cat 1 le
court assez du qatar voilà papa choix il
vous envie de cerner alors ça montait
pas trop mais j'ai eu de la chance parce
qu'il ya une somptueuse jeune femme qui
a dit mais je vais être vendu avec lui
non hélas tous les deux on a fait péter
le truc des milliers de catin bah ouais
ben j'imagine effet quoi alors bah on a
été vendu comme esclave tous les deux
non alors après il fallait être esclave
là j'ai quand même mis le holà away
seulement voilà j'ai juste pris 2,3
petit sac en effet une pomme dans la
ville avait deux paquebots la bouche
c'est fou franchement je m'attendais à
tout sauf à vous à la suite allé au 3g
travailler dans le x j'ai travaillé dans
le x ou pensé que c'était julien courbet
il a fait mais sans aucun doute c'est
vrai mais j'ai fait un porno d'or dans
le monde des fenêtres brisées
c'est pas moi et ça ça peut ça
s'appelait portes et fenêtres ouvertes
alors c'est qui qui a travaillé dans le
x pour l'instant on fait un sans faute
dans l'autre sens vous allez en mêlant
christophe sirugue s'est agi sciemment
la vidéo ce n'est à mon avis ils
remplacer les sexes avec sa caution
face à lui à mon avis une journée
typique qui pesait doublure foule
excuse-moi yahia patricia qui peut pas
faire ça tu peux nous passer merci on
l'appelle à tout-va paix la touche chez
le père et c'est le gars sont atteints
les cas tout flamme
ben oui alors il entend que j'avais pas
vu le film aux usa parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'il ya plus de tuv dans les
consciences et d'autres non
on en un an et demi j'ai fait mais je me
suis occupé des rp de la plus grosse
boîte de x au monde
non ça paye private 6 rives hathaway
voilà et j'ai géré pour deux festivals
de cannes d'affilée j'ai géré huard 2,4
ardeur pour mike day alors et vous avez
non figurez vous non c'est pas vrai nom
mais même là mais sert à losers et on
met le ver dans le fruit
w mais vous savez quoi non mais
franchement ça donne pas envie
ah ouais c'était très amusant mais ça
donne pas envie en revanche pas du tout
quoi et alors non en revanche c'était
très très bien pour entrer dans toutes
les soirées l'accord merci évidemment
consiste à ce que le secrétaire a pas et
continue on a continué j'ai fait un road
trip avec colombo alors je vous dire là
je vois je vois pas les secrets de la
poule secret de nabila on n'a pas encore
une habile à papa tête colons alors
jeune soro et fait paraître colombo quoi
ça sert avec les femmes qui aiment
l'aventuré vous cette fois c'est vous
non mais vous
une bonne productrice de secret story
alors qu'ils affrontaient colombo dans
l'équipe s'il vous plaît cccc julien
combes et je suis tapé 15 bornes avec
colombourg ne permet à vrai nom entre de
limiter et lui sur le siège passager
dans la 403 est en cours on a fait trop
autour de la plaine samedi c'était pour
une émission met donc je faisais bon
j'ai un colombo un bien ringard comme ça
il arrivait à pour jour julien d'eau qui
monte dans la voiture on a roulé on
s'est pas adressé la parole donnée trois
tours parce qu'il comprenait pas le
français et peter falk en fait oui mais
colombo je suis pas pourquoi on regarde
à chaque fois lundi la mère et ses
magnifiques mais c'est magnifique mais
bon c'est le seul truc
au bout de trois minutes tu sais qui a
tué 8 mai c'est celle que je chéris ça
tu vas mettre 12 heures à regarder pour
qu'à la fin ils disent bon c'est celui
là
mais là c'est la plus géniale je suis
policière il a une chance quand même
terrible ça veut dire qu'il est il tombe
direct il arrive que marc direct et
tombe sur l'assassin c'est à dire il a
même pas besoin de chercher il va tuer
les chouquettes massaï déjà dans la
boulangerie ça va mal il ne sent pas du
choc il a commis un meurtre
et comme on pouvait mais moi je vous dis
moi je suis sûr qu'à des vrais il ya
défaut en fait défaut défaut mecs qui
disent tellement une école à la fin ils
n'en peuvent plus il sait quoi me dit
c'est moi qui ai tué gatti lâche pas les
mecs
alors ensuite on a quoi il n'aura je
vois pas du tout ce que vous avez fait
hier j'ai déjeuné avec le pape qui a
déjeuné avec le pape à votre avis et
elle a tout fait pour vous
mais je n'aime pas mais aussi déjeuner
mais voilà
il avait raconté oui vous savez même
fait tomber votre bague twitter c'était
le précédant pâques parce que j'étais
enceinte jusqu'aux yeux et tétanisé les
plus pauvres sans
je sais pas je lance tu te lâches tacle
brosseau ici les insulter quelqu'un que
vous n'aimez pas 12 mais pipelette alors
j'étais enceinte ça coûte tellement cher
les taxis là bas que j'ai dû coucher sur
des bancs en étant enceinte
ouais et le pape on en a accompagné un
gamin qui voulait rencontrer le pape ne
pape avait accepté de le voir en tant
que journaliste j'ai passé le week end
en fait avec le pam d'accord et en fait
j'ai pris un tel savoir moment j'ai pu
courir à 7 heures du matin pendant la
main ce que le pape a arrêté la messe et
m'a demandé de quitter le poste il m'a
dit une nation et après il m'a béni mon
ventre et toutes les grandes choses donc
j'attends toujours
il a dit vous allez faire et vont les
choses le pô ville sympa mais bon il
demain voyons il s'appelle couple de
l'heure allez je suis fan de jacques
chirac alors c'est où il n'aura ou nabil
a alors à votre avis c'est qu'ils aient
nora qui est fan de jacques chirac est
la nôtre on peut dire que j'ai fait une
campagne pour jacques chirac s'est
séparé vous n'êtes pas trop je le trouve
trop chaud outre saisi
ouais il est vraiment trop mignon j'ai
des t-shirts jacques chirac sur la vie
de ma mère que c'est vrai ouais
mais j'aime ce soit en mêlée face à ce
vent ça c'est franchement c'est voilà
j'aime trop jacques chirac et jospin le
verra jamais alors c'est vrai mais aussi
jacques chirac nos gardes
si jacques chirac veut nous voir on va
regarder et ben si un jour au soir il
peut pas venir deux secondes avec
vermeulen
la ville a juste vous savez ce que vous
allez faire vous allez faire là il ya la
danse de la pluie
vous allez la faire la danse de
schirrhein salvador la caméra fait une
danse contact sur alzette si ceux-ci
vous allez voir je sais qu'il nous
regarde pas c'est comme ça
très fort et j'aimerais vraiment vous
rencontrer et désolé pour votre masse
mais vous je vous quitte je m'habille
l'arabie la décision en fait alors allé
là bas au fait on est une danse vous
allez faire l'émission de là-bas bon
pour jean michel maire et laurent
voulait voler
revenez randonnée elle est vraiment
parts égales j'ai frappé jakyval zina et
enfin donc et n'aura donc et n'aura fait
le grand écart sans échauffement mito
série nadia comaneci vraie vie de ma
mère comme suit si tu as un problème aux
ischio jambiers pour moi si je me
déchire
alors hier la caméra et là il aura donc
vous savez je l'admets la série des
caméras et là attention à we all away
ça va
bah voilà en tout cas il se retient
toujours intrigué je retiens deux choses
quand même
dans cette séquence à vous avez des
secrets vraiment pourri de leïla le pif
un bravo aux fonctions secret les
heureuses ou s'était pas sur ce cruel
sur les slips grecs ont heureusement sur
le secret ce n'est pas je ne porte pas
de culotte parce qu'avec le grand écart
on aurait cru